they're wicked sinful powerful and a
danger to others even if they're not
necessarily evil yes they are the devil
and we absolutely love them anime
wouldn't be the same if it weren't for
some utterly badass demons from the
yokai of ancient Japanese folklore to
the unholy trinity of Satan Lucifer and
Beelzebub the manga and anime industry
has always had a fascination with demons
from gegege no kitaro in the 1960s -
demon slayer in 2019 animate with demon
themes have held a special place in our
hearts it is after all such a versatile
theme that it fits just as easily in a
shounen adventure a shoujo romance or a
dark fantasy epic but what is it about
demons that we find so captivating I
guess it's their very nature isn't it
from what we've seen of anime demons
they're a bit of a hero and a bit of a
villain rolled into one even if they're
good they're rogues who take pleasure in
being bad and if they're evil well
they're just pure evil yep they're never
Undine tional thanks to the creativity
of anime these demons are never as
mundane as our cliched perception of
them as creatures with tails and horns
and that brings us to the subject of our
video today the top 10 most badass anime
demons love them or hate them you just
can't ignore them so without further ado
let's get started
[Music]
at number 10 we have the wimpiest devil
you've ever seen our Kyra is a cowardly
young man prone to bursting into tears
at the slightest provocation by a twist
of fate he's possessed by a powerful
demon and becomes devil man inheriting
all of the demons powers and memories he
also suddenly and inexplicably becomes
hotter
however he somehow manages to retain his
conscience and humanity and yes he is
still a crybaby
in a world where humans are under attack
from demons and being turned into demons
themselves this formerly awkward high
schooler is their greatest hope for
survival drenched in violence and neon
devil man crybaby is not your average
anime and its protagonist is not your
average he wrote while devil man is
supernaturally strong violent headstrong
and perverse arkiro brings a certain
vulnerability to this character that
makes it both badass and empathetic at
the same time
[Music]
our next entry is a foxy one who might
just be every girl's dream come true Dom
boy is a fox demon the guardian spirit
of a shrine and the hero of the popular
romance call me summer kiss the first
thing you notice about him is his
brooding good looks it's no wonder that
Nanami a powerless young girl who
suddenly inherits the shrine and becomes
its resident God falls for him big time
while he's the only hero of a shoujo
series on this list
da Moy is far from prince charming on
the contrary he's cold ill-tempered sly
and a sadist to boot what makes him
interesting is his duality he's the
second strongest youkai demon in the
world and feared by all mostly because
of his past as a Hellraiser he's also a
bit of a ladies man a flirt and a tease
and he's probably the only demon who
likes to see the contract with a kiss
that's badass on a whole different level
now when you say
[Music]
don't let his boyish looks fool you
recoil might be a regular boy by day but
watch out for him when his yokai blood
awakens at night completely different in
appearance from his elementary school
self night form Rikuo is much older has
red eyes and a shock of long white and
black hair that defies gravity is also a
strong fighter an excellent swordsman
and has a talent for winning over allies
this later helps him become the leader
of the night parade of a hundred demons
apparently that's a big achievement for
yokai whether he's stylish Lee lounging
on a sock or a tree drinking sake or
slashing his sword and baring his fangs
to his enemies there's something very
badass about this night out it probably
has something to do with his lineage
Rico's grandfather was a pretty powerful
demon in his prime even if he's now a
shrunken old man with a large head Nura
might not be the most popular anime
about demons out there but if you're a
fan of old-school yokai this is
definitely a show for you coming up next
is a character from a classic anime
Inuyasha is both the title of the anime
that aired in 2000 and it's hero a half
human and half dog demon this series has
plenty of badass yokai to choose from
there's Inuyasha himself who has a
boyish feistiness that younger audiences
would definitely relate to there's his
half-brother Sesshomaru
fully demon and as cool as he is
talented but our pick for today is
Naraku the first out-and-out bad guy on
this list Naraku is the personification
of deception driven by his desire to
purge his human side and become
invincible this demon antagonist is as
overpowered as they come while he has
enhanced physical strength Naraku
prefers to use his superior intellect to
fight his battles a master manipulator
he has the ability to mimic the
appearance of others and uses this to
play them against each other he's also a
shapeshifter and can use poison cast
spells and control corpses at will there
isn't much he can't do to be honest and
yes he's almost impossible to kill but
what makes Naraku so compelling is his
human side which he to his great dismay
just can't seem to get rid of till the
very end
demon number six is a different animal
altogether he's the most official demon
you've ever seen and the guy who runs
hell like a well-oiled machine whether
it's by sending sinners to the fiery pit
having them flogged by a torturer loving
bunny was stalked by an old hag who
loves to strip hazuki is the extremely
capable and super sadistic deputy of
King enma if this were a contest of
efficiency organizational skills and
micromanagement this scowling demon
would actually take the top spot as the
title of this superbly entertaining
anime suggests nothing fazes Hazuki and
nothing escapes him in the eighth cold
hell's the eight hotels and 272 other
subdivisions he presides over his
bureaucratic sensibilities and
troubleshooting skills might be
unparalleled but so is his appetite for
violence
just ask Beelzebub who might be second
only to Satan in European hell but has
been so traumatized by hazuki's mere
words that he can't help but cough up
blood whenever he sees him Hazuki
doesn't even spare his own boss
inflicting all kinds of abuse on the
easygoing enma physically beating him
with a spiked iron club or making him
lie on a bed of nails you better not get
on the wrong side of this one
we don't know all that much about Mouzon
as season 1 just scratch the surface of
his character but from what we saw of
him we can just say that he's vicious
powerful and dangerous he has the power
to turn ordinary humans into demons by
making them ingest his blood and turn
them into his slaves to the series here
at Don zero he's the demon responsible
for turning his sister into a demon and
slaughtering the rest of his family
underneath his polished and gentle
exterior Mouzon is a volatile seething
mass of malice he takes pleasure in
brutally killing his subordinates when
they failed to do his bidding he thinks
nothing of murdering a harmless drunk
simply for mocking him it's particularly
terrifying to see his stoic and detached
facade crumble and his violent rage
erupt but what perhaps makes him most
vile is his deception to the rest of the
world he appears to be a happy family
man and father to a young child hiding
in plain sight this is one dangerous
demon that would love to stay clear of
[Music]
no list of demons is complete without an
angel a fallen angel to be precise and
our next entry is a heavenly body quite
literally
Azazel is first and foremost strikingly
beautiful with white hair and large
black wings with his purple lips and
tall muscular frame clad in tight black
leather he looks more like a visual kei
rock star than Lucifer's
second-in-command
Azazel is also as devious as he is
good-looking he plays his enemies
against each other thinks nothing of
discarding a mission to fight worthy
opponents for his own amusement and even
sides with his enemies if it suits his
cause naturally he's extremely powerful
and adept at black magic just watch him
take on an entire army in his rag demon
form but there's another side to his
personality where he cares deeply for
those he takes under his wings even if
they're the child of his greatest
nemesis several popularity polls have
voted as they still the most popular
character of the series and we can tell
why he's evil but sometimes good he
kills but also protects he's crafty but
fiercely loyal and he's sweetly awkward
when he's hiding a pretty girl it's no
wonder the writers changed their minds
about killing him off early on as was
originally planned the oldest son and
heir-apparent of the demon king captain
of the strongest order of knights called
the seven deadly sins representative of
the sin of Wrath and former commander of
a group of elite demon warriors called
the 10 commandments Mellie Otis looks
nothing like the force of nature he is
cursed with immortality he has the
appearance of an adolescent an extremely
well muscled one that is despite being
more than 3,000 years old but don't let
his youthfulness lull you into a false
sense of calm with a list of powers and
abilities a mile long he can take down
giants and wave the tall and brawny barn
around like a piece of dirty laundry and
snap his wrist like a twig all this
without breaking a sweat
and rarely losing his wide-eyed smiley
look but he's a different customer
altogether when he unleashes his full
demonic powers and goes into assault
mode which Rob's him of his emotions and
turns him into a cold killing machine
if through-the-roof physical strength
and demonic powers aren't enough Mellie
Otis also has the perfect defense in
full counter with which he can deflect
any magic attack he's a feisty fiend and
that's why he's on this list
a member of team Yusuke yeah looks like
a regular human except for his crimson
eyes and his other defining feature the
third eye on his forehead which has
earned him the name master of the evil
eye this evil eye gives he a tremendous
powers and psychic abilities such as
telepathy and memory erasure
additionally his origin as a fire demon
born of an ice maiden makes him one of
the most formidable demons in his world
and that's not all he's a master
swordsman and so fast that he's capable
of slicing an opponent 16 times in the
blink of an eye he's the only one in his
team to not suffer a single defeat in
the dark tournament arc which is one of
the most well written arcs in shown in
history if such wrong power doesn't make
him badass there's his attitude he a is
extremely arrogant belittling both
humans for their emotional attachments
and weak demons for their lack of
strength
he's also ruthless violent and has a
notorious reputation as a killer yet PA
isn't all that bad
originally written as a secondary
antagonist before his popularity turned
him into one of the main protagonists
what makes yeh such an intriguing figure
is the reverence he sometimes shows for
the very human bonds he claims to
despise
[Music]
that brings us to the top of the tops
the biggest baddest demon of them all
Zod from the berserk franchise all it
takes is one good look to see how
ferocious and frightening he is whether
in his beast eale human form or his
Minotaur like apostle form Zod is your
worst nightmare come to life
this creature is fearsome even by the
standards of berserk a series known for
some truly terrifying characters via the
other apostles Griffiths femto
transformation or even the creepy
crimson by Haley until guts and Griffith
became the first in 300 years to wound
him
Zod had considered the skull like his
only worthy of rival it's because of his
long existence that this demon is called
Zod the immortal or even Nosferatu the
name usually associated with the 1922
silent horror masterpiece that was the
first adaptation of Dracula while Saad
is undeniably a god of the battlefield
he's not the unfeeling monster that he
appears to be
despite his bloodlust he doesn't kill
for the sake of killing his killing
sprees are actually a way to find worthy
adversaries of whom they are sadly far
too few for him but when he does meet
one they have his respect so it also
seems dismayed by his own strength
sometimes such character traits make him
an enigmatic figure among both men and
demons and on that note we've reached
the end of this video on the top 10 most
badass anime demons thanks for watching
till the end leave a comment if you
agree with this list or if you think
it's missing some worthy contenders I'd
love to hear from you on that actually
press the like button if you enjoyed the
video and subscribe to the channel for
much more content I'm here to entertain
and inform have a good day stay safe and
I'll see you next time on Vinny tube